Here's my answer. We got all the pieces.
We call all plays. We get back.
There is a collection of plays.
We sort them and take the last one--that'll be the highest.
We don't even have to specify what to sort by,
because of the score was the first element of the play,
so we're automatically sorting by that,
and then return the best one if there are any plays otherwise.
Otherwise, then I specified no play here in case I change my mind,
but I can say no play equals None.
Now, I could write something that plays a complete game,
but instead I'm just going to have a simple function showbest,
which takes a hand and a board, displays the current board, and then displays the best play.
When I type it in to the interpreter, this is what I get.
It found the backbench that we had sort of laid out there, scored 64 points,
and out of all the possible plays, it found the optimal one.
So, we did it. We made it all the way through. Congratulations.